all right jessica yes jessica uh where
are you from where'd you grow up um
carson carson california southern suburb
of l.a
um yeah so until i was like 14 and then
i went to long beach
nearby and uh tell me about your family
well
um i'm not very close to any of my
family members at all i've
my mom i left my mom's side when i was
12 years old you know
um
she's she was a single parent and
worked all the time all the time was
working and after work she'd
have boyfriends houses that she went to
for days at a time you know
so i'd often just
be at my friend's house across the
street or
should leave you alone yeah yeah i have
to i have it's me and i have two older
brothers
and uh but you know they're older
they're like 10 almost 10 years older
than me
so yeah definitely and the girl across
the street were where she was my friend
um i was always at their house
and but she was older than me too she's
like i was like 12 like no i was when i
moved on on neptune
i was um like in second
third grade and she was already like in
junior high that girl
so
you know and
from that summer on i mean i i woke up
one day and i was in a c cup already you
know i mean i was developed it was very
much like you know but she was always
gone and
she'd always make sure that we did have
like food in the fridge and stuff like
that and
you know but how would you describe your
childhood
lonely
and
sad you know i i
i was molested at eight years old
by my mom's second husband's
brother
and
he used to tell me that
if i said anything that the next day
would get worse
you know and so i remember
everybody would go to work and i'd go
run and hide under the bed
and and he'd come and he dragged me out
you know and the things that he did to
me as a little as a little girl like i
just don't understand
what you get pleasure from like doing
that you know he said
time into a chair and do
all kinds of
things you know he said
play with himself on my face you know
what i mean and like just weird things
like that you know that's
that definitely like
like really traumatized me you know like
i wasn't able to have like normal sexual
life until i did go to rehab later on in
life but i was able to accept that it
wasn't my fault or anything like that
you know did you do therapy um yeah well
i did a whole year of intensive um
outpatient program
later on because i had my children taken
away
when i was 18.
and
it took me like two and a half years to
start fighting for them but when i did
commit i committed to the fullest you
know what i mean
and um
um i have three well i had four but i
had a little girl that passed away you
know she
she she had a
swallowed the poop and the first poop
the mark they call it marcomium or
something like that
um i guess you ingested it and
suffocated basically like so
i didn't i didn't know i was in like i
had an emergency c-section
and
when i woke up i look at my husband and
i'm like where is she like you know
bring her to me you know and
he put his head down and they all the
doctors walk in and
and it was just sad it was like that's
nothing could prepare you for that
nothing i'm so sorry yeah i was supposed
to be my fourth kid easy peasy go you
know what i mean
but it was
traumatizing for me
so you you were using drugs at one point
and then you
well
i i started to you i started to play
with drugs when i was like 13. like play
with them and then remember i told you
the girl cross street was older than me
so um
i started i remember i did my first
crystal nest line and i was up for
days and my mom she wasn't there so like
you know i did whatever i wanted
but um
yeah and so
it was until um
when i met my my son's my first son's
dad um he was my boss at pizza loca my
manager
and he was just
not my usual type of guy that i like to
go out with or anything like that he was
kind of like a
like a
gangster-ish i believe it or not i don't
like i didn't look at that kind of guys
first but
he um we hung out after work we drank a
little bit you know a couple nights and
then one night he took me home and
basically like he fell in love with me
like instantly like and and i kind of
was just i was i'm not prepared for that
type of life to be settled down i was
only 17 at that time
and um i used to at this time i used to
get high with my mom actually we used to
i used to get high
i moved to long beach with my brother
and then i just get in a fight with my
brother and i he kicked me out i go with
my mom's house with her third her third
husband
and um
we all got high together me my mom and
him
and
that was
bad but anyways this guy kind of kind of
kept me away from that you know what i
mean and i would i would couldn't take
it anymore and i would run back to my
mom's house you know and he'd come after
three days and come pick me up
but i soon found out that he had a heart
condition
and that it was serious and we were in
and out of the hospitals you know and
so he took like a lot of medicine and i
was like what's up he take eight
eight different medicines and i didn't
understand like you know he was only 19
years old
and this this poor guy he like
in and out of the hospital like i said
and then one day he's like go find out
like what's going on i want to go home
and
i go and come back and he's on his knee
like proposing to me like you know and
asked me to marry him and i was 17.
i was gonna get married in april when i
turned 18 with him and he actually died
in march when i was three months
pregnant
from his kid yeah
i remember the day that i told him that
i was pregnant
he he cried tears of joy like no i've
never seen a man crying before
tears like big crocodiles he just he was
he thought he couldn't have any kids
because all the men he's like you know
but um
one day the hospital
here in downtown l.a like
he's talking to me like he knows he's
gonna go and i'm just like
i'll see you tomorrow like you know like
all the other times we were in the
hospital
and and he's i'm gonna always be with
you and the baby and don't worry and
you've given me the best joy in my life
you know like and i take off
and i get to my mom's
and not even an hour there
my mom had a a candle they call the
veladoras like the mexican lung candles
and it
shut off my mom says that's what she
said that's what she says but then
shortly after that the phone started to
ring
and there was his family telling me that
he let go he died
so basically like
i later on had a dream
with him and he told me that he was
waiting for me to leave
to let go you know what i mean because
he wanted me to see that
but basically he poured his life into me
with my son
and my son looks identical to him today
you know
and um
so yeah so after i had
my son
i was
well after my whole pregnancy actually i
lived with my grandma my mom my mom used
remember i told you so i didn't want to
be around that
and um
thank you
i lived at my grandparents house and my
no not my grandparents just my grandma
and my aunt and her and her
and my uncle her youngest brother and uh
they took good care of me you know and
i had like three baby showers everybody
was very supportive to me during that
time you know because
i had just buried my baby's dad you know
and um
i was alone
i was 17 i didn't know what to do
yet alone now i have to take care of a
baby you know what i mean i can barely
take care of myself
um
after i had him
i was strong you know and i i for i was
fortunate to find like a back house and
it was just me and him and i
i had a job at smart and final and i you
know my brother got me in there and i
was doing so good and i just
the depression of it
i started using
shortly after that
um i started using meth you know like
and
that's that was my
drug of choice at the time and
little by little i started
avalanching falling apart you know i
went to jail
i got caught um
i went to take this give a girl a ride
and
her mom was watching my son and i went
to jail
and i was freaked out i didn't know what
the [ __ ] was it happened to my son like
i don't even know what but i would and
somehow one way or another my mom
found out about it and she went and got
my son
she visited me at the jail with
my son you know and
my brother and they thought it was funny
to come see me and take the baby to see
me and how are the bologna sandwiches
you know like
it still didn't stop me from from
wanting to get high you know i i
continued to get high after that and i
lost the apartment
um sure i met um
my second my second kid's dad
re a rebound i would say like
it was really fast and that relationship
lasted short time and
i got pregnant right away and
he used to lie to me and cheat on me and
and i caught him one time i don't know
something just
i wanted to go outside to get a gas of
air or whatever the night time and i see
him getting dropped off at the corner by
girls
and i'm furious at this time you know
i'm pregnant
and we we're altercations and he drags
me by my hair while i'm pregnant you
know like
he dragged me by my hair and i'm like
one day you know what i mean like this
is
not the end of this [ __ ] like i'm gonna
you know the tables will turn you know
and um
sure enough they did turn his mom passed
away
around that same time
he went to jail for something that he
was um doing
fraudulent at his job
and
i had already had the baby
after that and
i used to
tell them i'm going to go to the store
and leave my two kids there and be gone
for days
like and i knew at this time he was on
house arrest and i would
he would chase me and i would like you
can't you can't
i might just
but
i don't really think that i loved him
loved him like that you know what i mean
like i just felt that he filled that
void for a little bit you know but once
he did that to me dragged me by my hair
never again
did i respect him again
and and that
that soon came came to an end too and
i had met
um
my
third kid's dad
but i i didn't just meet him i i knew
him from high school
and i ran into him in the streets and
we hung out and
we were hanging out and
i get the call from
my family members that
dcfs came and took my kids
you know
and
i show up to the building the ucfs
building and my baby's dad is there and
he
he sees who i get dropped off with
and i remember that day so clear he's he
spat in my face
calling me all kinds of names and it was
just it was horrible anyways
during that time it was the best thing
that could have happened to my kids
because at that time i was in
it it takes a lot out of a woman to say
that
she wasn't doing her job you know what i
mean and i wasn't doing my job
getting taken away from me was the best
thing that could have happened to them
because now they're being taken care of
now they're being loved
and basically it took me
two and a half years to even start
fighting for them
which
came that time and
i went to um
rehab
and just on time because i was about to
lose
i was about to lose my rights
and i find i go to the program and
everything and
guess what i find out i'm pregnant again
and here i am like my other two kids are
not with me like i can't i'm not gonna
have this baby like
i'm in the sober living at this time and
they convinced me
to not do my appointment
i don't regret it today you know it's my
son i love him he's
he's here now you know
but i did that outpatient program
for a whole year got my kids back
and uh i stayed clean for 10 years
behind this
10 years that's great
um my my baby's dad and i both were
clean for 10 years
and
but that that relationship that third
relationship that i had
when he got when we were
once i had my baby
my third baby
i don't know what what why he i felt
like he hated part of him hated me like
he treated me bad
he used he used to
like hit me like you know he hit me i've
got
stitches in my face here stitches in my
face here twice
for two different occasions
jealousy things you know i didn't even
have a cell phone during that time i
wasn't allowed to have a cell phone
yet alone facebook
or friends
he was very controlling and very
very very controlling and i never ever
once
called the cops on him never did any of
that
it was until and i never got my family
involved either i never ever called in
any of my family because i
it was embarrassing like it was
embarrassing to
to know that i'm not gonna go anywhere
i'm gonna stay with this man and to put
him out there like that i just couldn't
do it
i was only like allowed to have like one
friend really that he was okay with
and me and her used to
see each other at the grocery store like
i felt like
i was having an affair you know but i
was just go see her she would help me a
lot with learning how to cook and stuff
i didn't know how to cook you know my
mom wasn't there to teach me but now i'm
in a relationship and i have kids and i
want to learn how to cook so she's
showing me how and i would go to the
little mexican ladies uh at this at the
grocery store and i ask them how they
make this or how they make that you know
or even my friend she said help me a lot
but um one day it got serious that he
we had um separated for six for a month
one time
and during this time i knew um
he was the breadwinner and all this
stuff but
he got injured at work and
his acl
meniscus and all this stuff got torn and
so
with him being down i went to go get a
job
and i was working again at smart and
final
and uh i had
since i worked here before i was fast
you know and
i had to like refuse promotions because
he wasn't allowing me to work past three
o'clock like the kids
i had to be home before they
um one day
i tried to do during the time that we
separated my mom sneaked a cell phone in
and she bought me a cell phone
and
i'm such a
dummy because
i try to do the same thing that he did
to me like when i would look at his
phone
i would i turned it you know kind of
like what he did i was just doing it to
be a
like what he does
and
he just kind of smirked and at this i
was in the kitchen he grabs his cup of
noodles from the microwave and he throws
it at me boiling hot cup of noodles
and i on my chest and i just
you know
i just like felt this
burning in my chest and i don't know i i
just went in and grabbed a sweater and i
grabbed my little son and
and my other kids and i went on the bus
all three times and i was in the
hospital i went on the bus by myself
i had 30 degree burns on my chest you
know
and
that day i did call my brother and i
asked him to come pick me up and stuff
like that and
like an idiot i stayed
but um i never he never he never had
remorse for any of that stuff and that
day he
he begged me not to go and
you see the blisters that i had on my
chest
third degree burns from a cup of noodles
just for what
i didn't end up leaving my brother
left and
i stayed
and during this time
i'm really depressed and all this stuff
and i relapse
i started getting high again
but he didn't know
i was getting it from work
and with all this that i used to go pick
it up and all this stuff after afterward
he thought that i was cheating on him
and he asked me one day like are you
cheating on me and i said no you know
i'm just
i'm getting high you know and
that day
we started getting high together again
it wasn't long before
they somebody called dcfs on me again
they told me that they were gonna they
came and knocked on my door and i'm i'm
dummy i'm like i'm gonna be honest with
them and i'm gonna tell them everything
you know like so they'll work with me
and
my lawyer later on told me never to do
that again
always make sure that before you give
them the urine
the evidence that they need to get your
children away from you
you need to
get yourself clean no matter what it
takes they can threaten you all they
want
like
like oh if you don't show up today
you're gonna be dirty but no it doesn't
matter you're gonna give them the
specimen that makes you guilty
and if you don't give them the specimen
you're not guilty
well
they lied to me
they went and they took my kids from
school
put them in foster care separated my
kids and put them in foster care
and i was
i was living i was pissed i was so
pissed off like this how dare they lie
to me like
i know these people that these people
can
can and will
destroy
even even if i i say you know well i
mean you know it's i wasn't i wasn't i
wasn't the same jessica when i was 18
getting high this time i'm more paranoid
and whatever so for whatever reason i
think it was my my mother-in-law that
did it
called but because i had a previous case
that's why they took the kids and and
put them in foster care
i um
i knew what they were looking for i knew
what they wanted
so
they told me they were going to be gone
six months to a year and i got them back
in a month in three days because i knew
what time it was
and i would be down if i'm
gonna let my kids stay in foster care
and and i did get them back
and
during right before i got him back
um i had an issue with my mother-in-law
at that time
and my husband
he sold his um his classic 65
impala super sport
that he was getting ready to fix up and
everything
he sold it
just to get us
into an apartment so that the kids can
come home
that moment
my love for him grew so much
respect grew for him so much like he
changed
he never ever ever put hands on me again
ever after the
the cup of noodles incident he never
ever ever touched me again never ever
and in fact the tables turned kind of
you know i was
being colder and he was
but
he stepped up to the plate and he did
what he had to do to get my kids our
kids back
and we did and he did and i was so
i respected him so much more because of
that you know that was his classic car
baby like that was his
that was his new toy
and he gave it up just like that without
me even asking
to get her kids back and
yeah we were we were
we were good we were in our own
apartment away from his family away from
his mom
and he was working and we were doing was
so good
we planned
and talked about having another baby
and for
a woman to be able to give the man
what he's asking like we wanted a little
girl
we planned her we tried tried try tried
and i couldn't get pregnant
then he got
laid off of work
and we were struggling again and guess
what i find out i'm pregnant
well
it turned out to be a pretty hard
pregnancy as well and
this would have been my fourth this has
been my fourth kid
it should have been a piece of cake it
should have been
it was the hardest pregnancy i had i had
preeclampsia toxemia
my i had cankles i didn't even i didn't
even have ankles every few were so
swollen
but um
that was very short-lived too because
full term that i went and everything you
know people at this time they plan a
welcome home shower or whatever it was i
had to plan a funeral because she passed
away
she swallowed the
poop marcomium i think they call it
the autopsy revealed that it was in her
lungs so i don't know i didn't get to i
didn't get to see her alive or i didn't
by the time they had they handed her to
me she was already blue
they allowed
me and my family to have her in the
hospital room an entire day you know i
couldn't
i couldn't even
hold her because
it was killing me like
i had this bond with this little baby
already you know i
and
nobody ever tells you about this stuff
nobody ever
i didn't hear anything about this before
this you know what i mean i never heard
about them eating their poop or whatever
or not eating or ingesting it or
many people told me that it was the
hospital's fault or whatever i just
didn't even want to look into it because
i just
i just wanted to let it
let it let it go like you don't want to
keep remembering about it
that
event
was
the event that finally
brought me to my knees and
i didn't
i didn't know what to do you know um
my husband
the one that my rock
started using again
and i wasn't using
when i was
pregnant with roxanna i was good and
he started using and
was doing some way out stuff to meet the
kids in the middle of the night waking
us up throwing us out you know doing
some weird [ __ ]
so one day
my son at the time he's like 12 or 11
and he says mom i know how to get us out
of here you know
and i thought to myself like my son
should have been thinking about that
[ __ ]
what he's thinking all day at school
like how am i gonna get my mom out of
there
so that one night
meet the kids we grab whatever we can
carry
and we leave
i follow my son
and he had it all planned out like we
went to the park then we had to park
down the street
we went under the jungle gym and waymo
wait he's gonna pass by he had it down
like he knew
exactly
how it was going to happen and it did
happen that way and
eventually we escaped from there and we
went to i stayed at a friend's house
for a while but um
from that moment on we were um
in hotels
hotels
in and out of hotels
yeah
for a long time we were in and out of
hotels
i was uh
back onto drugs too
and
i needed to do whatever i needed to do
to
the only thing that i've ever known how
to do is clean
so i've always been good with
cleaning people's houses and
stuff like that you know and
that's how i paid for the hotel rooms
for
for years
years and years and years
my kids
i thought we were pretty close you know
and uh
around this whole time this whole entire
time in my whole entire life
i had a friend
his name was danny and um he loved me
since
he met me but
he was 8 20
20 years older than me and two i never
liked him like that you know so
i i met him because i used to clean his
house and um
he was always my friend though he was
there he was on the side
always watching me go through whatever
it is that i was going through always
there supportive always there
and he used to tell me all the time
honey why don't you just let me get you
and the kids out of the streets you know
and so i give it finally this is already
like four years after
roxanna passed away and i left my
husband it was four years
and i go with daddy you know and
me and the kids
daddy got us an apartment first
and he was a contractor
he was my friend since i was like 15
years old anyways
but i would live with him a year and a
half
and then he died right in front of me
after he died
i've been a wreck
i haven't been able to get out i've been
using i was using heroin
i was
injecting heroin
well when he died we were living in the
house in south central a
and the owner to that house
he did me really dirty he didn't be so
dirty
like daddy died and i was able to pay
the twenty three hundred dollars of rent
just from
like selling daddy's tools and because
daddy was a contractor i said that like
daddy's family wanted to come and take
everything from me you know and uh
daddy didn't even like his family he
didn't even
talk to them often at all he didn't talk
to them at all but they wanted to come
and take all his stuff for me you know
and so
my friend was like uh-uh you're not
gonna give them nothing you're gonna
tell them that possession is nine tenths
of the law and you're in possession of
all his [ __ ] so if they come onto your
property you're calling the cops you
know
and that that helped you know because
they they were threatening me
they were putting they were slandering
me on facebook his family like
they didn't even
know his favorite color his favorite
food yet alone
what he liked to listen to like how are
they going to come and tell these people
everything
but they knew better the people that
knew danny knew better they knew how
much he loved me and
so anyways
basically
i told the kids like what do you guys
want to do like should we just get
something
smaller an apartment like you don't just
and they wanted to hold on to the last
memory or a little bit that we could
have that he had
daddy was cool daddy was so cool
i was not prepared for that
after it was he died in november 2017
and i i kept the rent going until may
2018.
um i didn't have nowhere to go nowhere
and the kids
they went with the family member and
that's i've been lost since then i think
i've been pretty lost
[Music]
i i do fentanyl now and
[Music]
i have
a crystal meth
addiction as well
and but kids
they don't even talk to me tomorrow
my daughter turned she's uh she just
turned 19 the other day and
she did
she left
my mom's side because she was staying
with my mom and she's living with a 40
year old crib guy
she got jumped into a [ __ ] gay
a way far away she's in lag like away
from us
she just recently called my mom and told
her that i i stole 30 000 from her
i don't know
where she gets these ideas but basically
my mom already thinks that i'm a piece
of [ __ ] but by her telling her this
she thinks that i'm
the worst of the worst
and my oldest son is in colorado i think
i'm gonna be a grandma already
he got his girlfriend pregnant
he's only
20 years old
my 16 year old son does not talk to me
at all
in fact
my um
my
my ex he's sober now he's been sober
acting like two
years um
he stays with him and i
i only wish you know i gave that man so
many years of my life too and
during this time in between somewhere
all there i ended up in jail my first
time in the county
for 30 days and every day of those 30
days i cried trust to believe that
that's not a place for me
but uh
when i got out of jail
i got served with divorce papers
from my mom
my mom gave them to me
and i am i'm not gonna sign this you
know she's like you don't have to in the
state of california you're officially
divorced once you got the paperwork you
know
the man that i
forgave him time and time again time and
time again
i always
i always kind of figured that we were
going to end them back together you know
but
he couldn't even give me the respect to
talk to me in a conversation
talk to me about the divorce
anyways
he doesn't talk to me much so i don't
talk
to anybody
hardly
my family
[Music]
where do you stay now
in my car i stay in my car
in different places you know um
i do have some friends houses that let
me go and take a shower and whatnot you
know what
a more like i don't like to um i don't
like to
to bother people you know and i don't
like people to judge me so much you know
everybody has something to say always
you know i
it's not my fault that i was
not born ugly you know what i mean
i get
i get
judged a lot and i get [ __ ] talked about
you know and for nobody really knows me
nobody knows what i
nobody knows what i really try to do
nobody sees that i have my own fluff and
fold delivery service
then i'm trying to start my own um teeth
bleed
business too you know uh which my
flip-flop company is called just clean
with a k and then uh my bleed business
is just bling
so i'm trying to um
i'm not just trying to give up you know
what i mean i'm just trying to like roll
over and give up
i am trying to i know that i know that
i will get blessed probably until i am
clean you know but it is coming
i feel it
it doesn't do nothing for me to work
but i feel really depressed
and depression is above it's for real it
really is
and when you're alone
it's not good
thoughts are not good
no especially sitting in your car all
day
if i don't have work yes i do stay in my
car all day um but if i have
things to do
i'll be doing my things you know
gas is expensive
like yo i don't have
i don't have like no sugar daddies or
nothing like that yeah i don't i don't
have that
and i'm very i'm a very powerful person
so like i don't i can't panhandle i
can't not not shooting on anybody who
does but
i've always been able to
you know even even to my
like my uh
the people that i get the drugstore i'm
like you know
i've always offered to clean
do their laundry like you know
like i've always said i got a brain i
don't got to give brain to get what i
want you know
again not shooting on anyone who does
but that's just not who i am
i'm i've been i've been seagull
like seagull singles since i've never
been single since i was 17 years old
never until
it's been about
well daddy died
in 2017 and i started seeing somebody
like about a year after
i don't even want to get started on that
guy
i i learned what a narcissist was
and uh
he did
some
really really
messed up stuff to me and um
i tell i tell these sometimes that i
mean you know
guys don't want to love me they don't
want to take care of me they just want
to [ __ ] me you know that's
all they want to do
like it sucks
because
i can turn heads anywhere i go
but they don't
they don't want they just want me for a
couple hours
and i know that
and that sucks
i'm not young and dumb anymore i don't
fall for it
i i don't know when i i used to fall for
this long time like you know
that people were
i i
i have been speaking to
[Music]
someone
but it's a just slow thing and
he's
far and uh
i don't think that i'm
i don't have anything to offer right now
i want to get better you know
what's your plan now
[Music]
i need to get off drugs you know and um
you know that the whole
rehab thing it
i feel like it just kind of like it's a
setup like because you get removed from
life
real life
and then
you're not you're you're taken um
you're not put into situations i i know
that when i was ready the last time i
remember when i got clean for 10 years i
was ready i was done with this [ __ ] i
was just done and i did it and i was
around it and i did it you know
of course like
i have all of these new
things that i need to deal with you know
and um i haven't grieved properly
since
rocks since roger my maybe said that i
had
roger roxanna danny
i have to deal with that
i need to deal with that
i need to get i'm so lonely you know
it's very lonely
it's hard to not want to believe
everybody everything that everybody
tells you
because believe me
i'm here i've heard some stories
just to try to get into my pants
yeah you're still helpful
very
that's great
that'll be the key
yeah
i just i see my daughter
and i'm afraid that
she's with
you know um
reminded me one of the videos that you
had like it reminded me because the girl
got the guy's name tattooed on her face
right
and i was like be losing on my
daughter's instagram page and
she
got
this 44
year old man's name on her face but he
says he's not picking her out
and i'm afraid that that's what's
happening
i don't know she's always calling my
family for money i don't understand
i'm just i know that i need to get right
so
i can
find it my kids at home that they can
always go home to because
lord knows i don't have that
i don't have
a home that i could just
oh i gotta fight over here let me go
home but so mom you know you know i
don't i never know
yeah the drugs are derailed everything
for you
yeah but
dude just like that that you
i can't even get out anymore like you
know what i mean i pay a lot of money
for this stuff and it's like
that makes me even more depressed to be
honest with you
i am like
probably at my wit's ed's already like
you know
is your lowest point right now
yeah
pretty much
like because i don't
think i told you i'm talking to somebody
like i don't
he doesn't know about this [ __ ] that i
do you know like it's embarrassing to me
i don't have nothing to offer so
sometimes i just
oh i'm working i'm working you know what
i mean like it's just
i wish i could be born a little bit more
i know i can't i just
gotta do it
i can't plan this [ __ ] i just gotta do
it
it's hard
no i gotta stop saying that i gotta stop
saying that it's hard because
i set myself up for that you can do it
yeah
i hope so because you said i don't look
like a drug addict
i don't no
not at all for many years they've been
checked out yeah
i used to slap heroin
bad you never know i just wanted i
wanted to
fix and not wake up you know what i mean
depression is tells you things like you
know
well you've been through a lot you've
been through some really tough
things
so depression
isn't a surprising reaction to that
yeah but you know people need to realize
that like no not tough love doesn't work
for everybody one
two
sometimes little things like a full call
to make sure you know i'm okay
that makes me feel good makes me feel
like i'm thought about needed wanted
that goes a long way
i don't get
no calls
i don't even know why i pay full
yeah
all right jessica thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you for having me i hope you stay
strong and
break away from this i will i do i do do
too i know
maybe uh
yeah you can do it i'm hopeful you know
yeah
all right thank you very much
you're welcome
you